uh let me ask you about because you
mentioned and nyu
um what i find fascinating is how much
amazing researchers
speaking of science right uh
studying the effects of psilocybin
studying the effects of various
psychedelics mdma on the human mind
right now for helping people but i'm
hoping there'll be studies
soon
at hopkins and elsewhere that allow
people that are kind of more
quote-unquote creatives or
regular people that don't have a
particular demon they're trying to work
through the a problem they're trying to
work through but
more like to see what can i
find if i utilize psychedelics to
explore is there something you could say
that is exciting to you that's promising
about
the future what currently is going on
but also the future of psychedelics
research yeah hopkins and elsewhere the
healthy normals the healthy norms
i was looking for the right words
because normal doesn't feel healthy
doesn't feel like a good term and normal
doesn't feel like a good term because
we're all pretty messed up and we're all
weird so well those with ontological
angst in that case great maybe that'll
be a future dsm qualification yeah um
there's no doubt that that things like
psilocybe and mdma
are are useful for things like anxiety
depression end-of-life distress ptsd
alcoholism you name it
and it's largely because of the clinical
research that mdma and psilocybin will
probably be legal in some fda regulated
way in the next five years um but i mean
again i start the first page of my book
with this question why why do
psychedelics work
across all these different conditions
and uh the best that i could find is is
the meaning right um tony bossus at nyu
talks about psilocybin for example as
meaning making medicine
which is interesting because it puts it
somewhere between a therapeutic and
again this this ontological
instigator
what is it about psychedelics that
creates
these mystical experiences or mystical
like experiences you can call them
emotional breakthroughs you can call
them moments of awe
i do think we get locked up in the
language and we're somewhere between
science and religion here
including legally so the fda is one
route to this what excites me about
psychedelics is the first amendment what
is this going to mean for religion the
freedom of religion being the first
thing that's mentioned in the first
amendment before freedom of speech
freedom of assembly oh interesting yeah
if america is known for anything it's
it's a refuge for uh religious pioneers
and so we already have the native
american church brazilian spawn churches
that are using psychedelics but what
would happen if judaism or christianity
or islam or to begin incorporating
the very ritual very sacred
and discreet use of psychedelics as part
of their liturgy so not replacing the
sunday eucharist in the case of
christianity but
part of the extra uh extra credit
dimension of the credit and then we can
through practice figure out how
essential it is it could be a minor
thing it could be a major thing
that's another thing i wanted to kind of
ask you is um i recently despite the
fact that i'm eating a huge amount of
meat i'm getting fat
i'm loving it i'm you know this is
actually
uh as of two days ago i started this
long road to training for david goggins
to training back to
getting back to competing in jiu jitsu
so
the fun is over but i also partake in
fasting and there was a very
strong
there's an almost like a
hallucinogenic aspect of fasting because
it was especially because it was a 72
hour fast versus a more common fast that
i do which is 24 hours
you know uh
and a bunch of people talk about
throughout history about the value of
fasting in having these kind of
visual these kind of intellectual
experiences
uh also there's meditation sam harris
with the hoodie uh
do you have a sense that um
those other
rituals of fasting of meditation and
maybe other things
could uh
could be as essential or more essential
to the religious experience as
psychedelics
yes if not
and this is going to sound weird but
maybe not if more so
um i look at psychedelics as a catalyst
for spiritual investigation not as the
superficial means to an end i i think
their their value
is in kind of
serving as a google maps for the kingdom
of heaven um
all right
i like this
well so rom das teacher said that when
he was was offered psychedelics that um
it'll it'll get you in the room with
jesus but it won't keep you there
okay yeah and i think that's all well
and good but what if you don't know
where the house is in the first place
what if you've never had a mystical
experience what if what if religion
is anathema to you what if you hate god
what if all these words mean nothing to
you and they probably do for many many
people and it's perfectly understandable
i think that we've we've lost the
coordinates to these irrational states
again that were prized throughout
antiquity and that continue to be prized
by the mystical communities even in big
organized religion it just doesn't
filter out that much and so psychedelics
in my mind
help orient
our minds bodies and souls towards the
irrational right we talked about
mckenna's invisible world that seems to
have this symbiosis with our own and
perhaps has this higher intent for us um
you could very well
just you know take catalog of your
dreams right and that would do it too
but psychedelics seem to be particularly
fast acting um particularly potent and
very reliable especially in the clinical
studies and so i looked at them as as
biochemical discoveries like like huxley
did maybe it's once
in your life or infrequently right um
but maybe that's the beginning of a
genuine introspection and a life well
examined as the ancients always
instructed us yeah it does seem like in
the research this um the effect of
psychedelics always comes with the
integration
where you uh use it just like you said
as a catalyst
for thinking through stuff it's not it's
not going to be i don't even know if
google maps
oh maybe maybe google maps is the right
analogy but it doesn't do the driving
for you
you still have to do the driving uh it
just kind of gives you the directions
so after you come come down from the
trip or whatever you still have to drive
you